good afternoon
on monday ontario started the gradual
reopening and i want to thank ontarians
for the sacrifices they have made that
allowed us to get to this point
because of your efforts to help blunt
the transmission of omicron our health
care indicators suggest a general
improvement in the covet 19 situation in
the province thank you
lundy dernier la rey
however we recognize that some areas of
the province still have precarious and
strained healthcare capacity
and we still need to come together as a
province to support all regions as we
move ahead in our reopening
while the coming weeks will continue to
be difficult for our hospital system the
number of hospitalizations is currently
stable and given current trends we are
more confident in our ability to ensure
capacity across the province so that all
ontarians can get care at the right time
and at the right place
icu numbers remain high but the number
of covet 19 patients are now starting to
decrease
and we have increased capacity to
provide care to those who need it
the percent positivity of tests
continues to decrease
with our average this past week
declining to fourteen point six four
percent
from eighteen point four percent the
week prior
based on the current stabilization in
ontario's testing strategy this is
likely reflective of a real decline
long-term care outbreaks are also
declining and we recently saw the first
decline in the number of active resident
cases in long-term care since the
omicron variant became the dominant
strain
there's also been an increase of
wastewater sites across the province
reporting a downward trend in covet 19
detections
these trends are encouraging but we must
remain vigilant and adhere to the
measures that are helping reduce
transmission
such as staying home when you're sick
wearing a well-fitted mask distancing
and getting vaccinated and boosted
these individual actions will lead to
our collective protection
i also want to take this opportunity to
acknowledge our educators parents and
students for their dedication to making
the return to in-person learning as
successful and as safe as possible
in the last week approximately 13.3
percent of students and staff were
absent each day and over 94 percent of
schools have reported less than 30
percent of students and staff absent
we also saw less than one percent of
schools were closed each day
so only seven out of four thousand eight
hundred and forty four schools
and these closures are typically due to
operational challenges such such as
staff shortages
keeping our children and youth in school
is critical to their mental health and
well-being and i thank you for all
the support you're doing for our
children's academic success
in addition to all the measures in place
at schools to help them
remain as safe as possible vaccination
is also a key and the vaccines we have
are safe and effective and the best way
to protect our children from kovid 19.
to date 87.1 percent of ontarians age 12
to 17 have received one dose of a covet
19 vaccine and 83.6 percent are fully
vaccinated and we continue to make
progress in our vaccination campaign for
our five to 11 year olds
53.9 percent have received one dose and
20.2 percent are fully immunized we
increase that by 10 percent in january
alone so thank you to the parents
as we seek to improve our immunization
rates in our youngest eligible age group
it is our goal to ensure that parents of
children feel well informed and safe
when deciding to have their children
immunized
the children's health coalition in
collaboration with the hospital for sick
children has launched a children's
vaccine confidence campaign to provide
parents and caregivers with information
to make an informed decision
parents caregivers and children are also
encouraged to call the provincial
vaccine confidence line or book a
confidential phone appointment with sick
kids clinician through their covet 19
vaccine consultation service
i know that for parents
nothing is more important than the
health and well-being
of their children and have incredible
sources of information they can rely on
to be scientific and factually correct
is important
the resources are there to help you
answer all the questions you may have
as are your trusted health care
professionals
jose
though vaccination remains key we do
have antivirals available to help us
manage the impact of this virus
because of the limited supply of
paxlovid which is an outpatient oral
treatment we are prioritizing the
distribution to unvaccinated individuals
who are at risk of severe outcomes of
covid19 infection including
hospitalization
this includes unvaccinated seniors aged
60 and over
first nations inuit and metis
individuals age 50 and over
and individuals age 50 and over with
underlying risk factors
we are also prioritizing
immunocompromised individuals 18 and
over regardless of their vaccine status
as of today 12
treatment courses of paxlovit have been
distributed through the 15 sites
though
it is no substitute for immunization
paxlovid is available and will
significantly reduce the risk of
hospitalization if taken within five
days
of symptom onset and in the randomized
controlled trials they reduce the risk
by 88 percent
if you think you may be eligible to
receive pacslovid you can contact your
primary care provider
call telehealth ontario or visit a
covid19 clinical assessment center
community
i also wanted to mention an update on
our pcr testing eligibility we continue
to prioritize pcr testing for those at
the highest risk of severe outcomes
including those eligible for covet 19
treatments such as antivirals those who
work and live in the highest risk
settings and patient facing health care
workers we are expanding eligibility to
now include household members
of patient-facing health care workers in
order to support timely identification
of cases in healthcare workers in
ongoing delivery of healthcare services
i want to thank ontarians for the
sacrifices they have made and for their
continued cooperation when it comes to
following the public health measures
that we know
work
your actions are having an impact the
trends are looking
positive but we must remain cautious and
our continued reopening efforts must be
implemented cautiously thank you merci
we'll go to the phone lines for
questions just a reminder it's one
question one follow-up over to the first
question please
from allison jones at the canadian press
hi dr moore
um
given the significant number of people
who were infected with omicron over the
past two months i think a lot of people
are curious about what sort of immunity
that confers
if you were fully vaccinated and got
omicron or even boosted and got omicron
can you
throw caution to the wind
assume you've got super immunity or are
people who had omicron susceptible to
being re-infected with omicron i think
there's some preliminary research out
there but is ontario tracking this
so a really good question um it it
appears with omicron if you get natural
immunity so you're not vaccinated and
you get infected by omicron
you do have some immunity against
further reinfection but there is
significantly a risk for re-infection
from omicron over time
so we're not confident in how long that
duration of immunity is from natural
exposure yet it's still early days we
have heard from our immunologist
partners
that if you have had natural infection
and you get an mrna booster vaccine that
significantly adds to your level of
protection and
length of protection against omicron
so it has been the recommendation from
the national advisory committee to
get immunized with that mrna vaccine
even if you've had natural exposure
given that it provides longer
and stronger and more beneficial
protection against any risk for
re-infection so you may and layman's
turns consider getting infected
naturally by omicron as
almost equal to one dose of vaccine
and subsequent benefit
is uh maintained by having a follow-up
vaccine uh
obviously after complete resolution of
symptoms and it's best to actually have
a you know a roughly eight-week minimum
time delay um from your first exposure
that will give you much longer
lasting and acting protection
so pretty complex question but thanks
for asking it
um yeah
a slightly different topic you and some
other health officials and government
officials have started talking recently
about learning to live with covet and
i'm wondering if you could give us a
fuller picture of what that looks like
does it mean just returning to our 2019
way of life or does it mean something
else
yeah i think we really have to
approach
the reality that omicron is highly
infectious and is going to be difficult
to control and limit
and now that we have safe and effective
vaccines
as well as safe and effective outpatient
treatments and inpatient treatments it
comes
to a time where we're going to have to
decide how many public health measures
we'll maintain going forward
and
how we can try to maintain our mental
physical social economic and educational
well-being in the face
of an ongoing threat from this strain of
viruses
i think it's a discussion we have to
have at a societal level of what our
values are
but with these tools that we now have in
place i think the the discussion has to
occur
and we have to decide as a society how
many public health measures we want to
just recommend and or maintain in a
legal fashion to limit the spread of the
viruses i think that discussion should
happen soon given that
some of our trending is heading in the
right direction we're following other
countries such as the uk south africa
that are also on downward trends from
omicron
and yet don't have the same level of
public health measures in place so it'll
be a societal discussion um
and government will make the eventual
decisions
but i think it's worthwhile
as a society to start having those
discussions
next question
from
randall denley at the national post
hello dr mark
i
looking at the
[Music]
vaccine dashboard and i know that the
case levels between
comparing the vaccinated unvaccinated
are quite similar to each other
i'm also seeing some international
studies saying that the
similar rates of transmission between
the two groups i wonder what your
thoughts are now did you unvaccinate
still pose
a greater threat
of transmission than the vaccinated in
ontario
so well
really complex question um
the
two doses of vaccine
with omicron don't seem to limit the
risk of transmission significantly
and
though three doses can give you a much
better protection against the risk of
transmission
so up to 60 percent uh benefit on
decreasing your risk of transmission so
the the problem is now that the this
vaccine that we have against omicron
doesn't um cause sterile immunity
doesn't limit the risk of an immunized
person carrying the virus significantly
with two doses three doses certainly
does
i should say though the major caveat and
protection of the vaccine is that it
limits the severe outcomes in recent
studies that are going to get published
from ontario data show
up to 95 percent protection of three
doses against severe outcomes associated
with this virus so
your very good point the vaccine isn't
providing significant benefit at two
doses against the risk of transmission
uh as compared to someone unvaccinated
but it provides excellent benefit and
what i think most people want is to
avoid hospitalization and ending up in
the intensive care unit or frankly dying
from this virus
the vaccine protects significantly
against those severe outcomes um
so when when we see a vaccine that
doesn't provide the sterile immunity
like
it did provide against delta we have to
reassess
some of the public health measures that
we put in place reassess
whether
we maintain a proof of vaccination
certification process
uh given the decreased benefit against
transmission but reiterating three doses
does provide a significant benefit
follow-up
i
anticipated my second question i was
going to ask you whether that
uh the difference between the two is
enough now to justify a
passport system although we have one in
place apparently until
march the 15th but let me rephrase it
because i think you said for two doses
no if i hear you correctly but
is your sense that we should keep
passports and go with three doses
or get rid of passwords i think we have
to reassess the value of the passports
in the coming
weeks and months and clearly again
that's a government decision the the
main benefit of the passport system now
is that against severe outcomes uh we
are well protected with two doses uh and
hence increased socialization of someone
unvaccinated in increasing their risk of
getting omicron through accessing any of
these venues does increase their
personal risk so it does protect the
unvaccinated person
well against
transmission and
against severe outcomes
by not being able to access mass
gatherings and or many of these venues
but
my preference would be that we only have
6.7 million ontarians that taken
advantage of the third dose is that more
ontarians especially if you've got any
chronic underlying illness
and or
by age alone 50 and up
i would really suggest you get that
third dose if you haven't already it is
proving to be so beneficial against
the risk of transmission but also
against
severe outcomes
so
we just have to be honest about the
benefits now of two doses of the vaccine
and review the implications for all of
our public health measures that we put
in place
and i think those discussions will will
be happening in the coming weeks and
months
as you've raised russell
next question
from matthew bingley at the global news
hi doctor i'd just like to follow up on
allison's question uh you you said that
you know some of those decisions would
have to be uh made at a societal level
of of what measures might need to be
considered going forward i'm wondering
what options you would actually suggest
in in your capacity as as
public health measures that that would
be necessary to keep around for a while
so the general recommendations
on distancing and hand hygiene
i think
are prudent and reasonable
but
clearly
the most important one
and probably the last one to go will be
masking
given that masking protects
me it protects you uh but it protects
the most vulnerable members of our
community from transmission and and i
think that will be probably the last of
the public health measures to go um we
just had a brief discussion about the
proof of vaccination three doses is so
much superior to two doses against risk
of transmission uh and severe outcomes
that i hope more ontarians embrace it um
yeah but we're awaiting federal guidance
on whether um their proof of vaccination
for international travel will move to
three vaccines etc um but in in the
interim uh of all the measures uh uh i
think the masking will be the last to go
we'll certainly have to review the proof
of vaccination uh i think it's common
sense uh on
hand hygiene and distancing um
uh and i would hope even if we don't
mandate masking that anyone that's
vulnerable um to this virus will
continue to mask and that it become a
community standard especially
as we return into the fall where we
anticipate uh all the respiratory
viruses will try to come back and spread
amongst us
follow-up
thank you and on
ba2 uh with the number of um cases that
have been seen to take over in denmark
with with our reopening i'm wondering
uh
how many cases you're currently tracking
in the province and and what concerns
you have as as more people begin to go
out and
uh
it has the opportunity to spread more
here
well great question it's still early
days with ba2 we've had 29
cases of
ba2 detected in ontario through our
robust whole genome sequencing
strategy
those were reported to us
yesterday um clinically we're not seeing
any different outcomes it's just very
small numbers between
ba2 and others in terms of the
hospitalization rate of those 29 cases
or severe outcomes
it's something i think internationally
we're going to need large numbers to be
able to ascertain if there's an increase
in virulence we do anticipate that
there's an increase in transmissibility
of ba2
we will be monitoring about vaccine
effectiveness against it but there's
nothing from the our immunologists or
public health ontario scientists that
have told us that they're concerned
about vaccine escape with this strain
and given that we have good cellular
immunity against
omicron we anticipate having the same
against the ba2
strain of it
so it's early days we're monitoring the
situation very closely um that 29 cases
is an underrepresentation given that
it's the the whole genome sequencing
of the level of activity in our
community um and we'll be monitoring it
very closely going forward
next question
from stella dupree radio
hello dr moore
so i have a question for you you said
that we have to start learning to live
with kovid and i was wondering what does
that look like because we lived with
where we must masks staying home for
extended period of time with a runny
nose standing six feet apart
when does that end because that's not
how we live with other viruses
yeah it'll be a journey for us um
stella that's a great question we've had
two years where we've been very fearful
of this virus uh and and the strains
have changed over time uh we're we're
fortunate that with omicron it has less
severe outcomes than the previous
strains
and we're fortunate that we have safe
and effective vaccines that prevent
severe outcomes and now we have
good oral outpatient antiviral therapies
so as a society um to decrease that fear
will take time
for us to normalize living with this
virus
i i think some of the basic tenets that
we've learned over the last two years we
will maintain especially going into the
fall of hand hygiene and distancing many
of us will continue to wear masks even
if they're not mandated at that time
and i i do believe that
over time we won't have proof of
immunization
necessary to to get into certain venues
clearly the federal government has
responsibilities for international
travel and whether that will be
maintained but all of that has to get
reviewed
i would think the same tenants that if
you do have symptoms of a virus no
matter what virus a fever a cough or
runny nose and certainly there's
hundreds of different viruses that can
cause those symptoms that you would stay
home if you're ill
that you'd come back to work once your
symptoms have recovered
and that once at work you'd still
practice good hand hygiene monitoring
your symptoms etc so it'll be a journey
as a society to come out of this
and to normalize
omicron and covid as we've normalized
all the other viruses
and i do think we'll also have the
addition of an annual vaccine for the
next several years
just to maintain
immune protection against any surges of
hospitalization
and i'm looking forward to hearing from
the immunization companies whether
that'll get integrated with an influenza
vaccine which would certainly make it
easier from a patient vantage point
follow-up
uh yes dr moore i was wondering do you
consider that the worst of the pandemic
is behind us
i've been humbled by this virus too many
times we're in wave five now and alpha
beta gamma delta and now omicron
we know this virus wants to mutate
roughly two significant mutations
every month
and any one of them can emerge and
become a dominant strain
so i
hopeful i'm very hopeful about the
impact of the vaccine campaign as well
as the oral outpatient antiviral
therapies we now have available to us
that we can get back
to a more normal lifestyle but will be
have to be very cautious
we are monitoring the situation
internationally with our federal
partners looking
and adhering to
our surveillance obligations to detect
any new strains within ontario
and sharing that federally and then
internationally and and likewise i'm
confident all countries around the globe
are trying to identify if there's new
strains developing and taking
appropriate public health actions so
we're not out of the woods yet we still
have to be cautious um but we've learned
significantly from the last two years
and i do believe we're in a much better
position to learn to live with this
virus and to be less fearful of it
last question
from john mcgrath that's pvo
uh good afternoon doctor
in terms of the testing i i note that
you've expanded the eligibility for pcr
testing today but
you know
the the science table for example says
you know it's very challenging to do
modeling right now because the testing
is so limited we don't have an estimate
of what the the province-wide our number
is um
you know the the lack of testing really
is is hampering some of what we can say
we know
about uh what is going on in the
province right now and so i'm curious
why we aren't talking about a more
um
aggressive approach to to
expanding testing again uh if for no
other reason than to get a better idea
of what's going on well thanks john so
the pcr testing capacity in ontario is a
finite resource and we have to use it
judiciously we've also complemented the
pcr capacity with a very robust uh rapid
antigen testing capacity and
we and hopefully the supply will improve
from the federal government where we can
have have it even more widely available
uh 3.9 million rits distributed to
students across our elementary and
secondary schools that will be expanded
uh
and
replenished over time we continue to
have rapid androgen testing availability
to our long-term care partners
acute care partners as well for
screening for workers
and education workers as well so we're
using multiple different testing
modalities
that are complementary but i have to
acknowledge the pcr testing is a finite
capacity that we have to use judiciously
and we're just now getting our
turnaround time
to uh for within 48 hours
to to an acceptable 80 percent level
where we can action them because we need
to use pcr tests
in the high-risk congregate settings
hospital settings to help us
document who should and can receive
therapies because they're dependent upon
a pcr test being positive
so bear with us we're reviewing the
capacity on a regular basis the testing
expert panel gives us advice
on how we can judiciously slowly expand
the use
of the pcr capacity that we built in
ontario
and
i i think we should acknowledge we've
got good data coming from our hospitals
now on the total number of people
hospitalized which is on the decline
total number of people in the intensive
care unit
which is again on the decline
and the wastewater
surveillance system that is in
across ontario is showing also a decline
so we have multiple surveillance and
data points that are helping us give us
situational awareness
and from my vantage point monitoring all
of these we're trending in the right
direction we know reopening the economy
could lead to some
rough times in february as we have
increased socialization and
increased risk trends to transmission
but we'll monitor that and we've built
good hospital capacity for february so i
think january was tough
february will be better i do think see
things improving further in march
and then hopefully a low
endemic rate in april all the meanwhile
i hope ontarians come forward and
continue to take advantage of our robust
immunization strategy continue to take
advantage of the third doses which are
so protective against severe outcomes
i'd love more ontarians to come forward
for that third dose 84 days after your
last
to get the best protection we can from
these safe and effective vaccines
follow-up and this is the last question
uh there were i guess problems with you
know relying too much on the the daily
case count but it was it was the most
leading indicator that we had in terms
of warning us when a spike in
hospitalizations was coming so
do you see
things like the wastewater surveillance
as a substitute for that as a sort of an
early warning system or is are we going
to have to
expand pcr testing in a way that if we
don't have wide open eligibility is
there a way to
expand it in a way that restores
a bit more of a maybe a
statistical sample if you know what i
mean
that's a really good point so
we to be clear with 30 000 pcr tests
done on average last week uh percent
positivity is on the decline so to me it
that's a good
signal it's reliable now that it's a
stable population that's getting tested
i think the uh the wastewater
surveillance at a population level gives
us a good indication as well since so
many communities are seeing a decline in
the in the positivity and and then we're
what we traditionally do for respiratory
viruses is we have sentinel primary care
providers or sentinel uh uh
partners uh that tests every third or
fifth patient that show up with a
respiratory
complaint
of a virus like nature and we sample
them from multiple different viruses to
get awareness of what's the predominant
virus so outside of covid right now it's
respiratory syncytial virus is is the
significant uh strain that's
spreading across ontario uh we need to
have a a a robust sentinel surveillance
network that will also provide us with
input
on what are the circulating viruses and
we're working on having that up and
running for the this fall
so we can inform people of what's the
dominant virus so that they're aware and
they can take appropriate precautions
some spread more rapidly through
touching surfaces some
are more airborne and some are a mix
and we'll be able to communicate that
risk as schools reopen in the fall
and we move indoors in the in the winter
of 2022-23
thanks everyone